cigare alive 15h bonjour bienvenue 100
jours de bruit de char 100 jours deux
coups de fusil 100 jours de
bombardements sans jour de ville
détruite 100 jours de vie détruites cent
jours de peur sont jours de morts et 100
jours de guerre bonjour alexis faire de
chaque jour thibault oui ça fait bizarre
mais ça fait cinq jours on a fait le
premier live via il ya quasiment soir
jouant peut-être 90 jours merci d'être
ici alexis adjoint au pôle actu du
figaro très au fait de tout ce qui se
passe en ukraine vous rappelez ya cent
jours un peu plus
on y croyait à peine en tout cas en
france beaucoup disaient non c'est
impossible admire poutine n'envahira pas
l'ukraine tout cas les autorités
françaises contrairement aux autorités
américaines par exemple ne croyer
beaucoup moins l'hypothèse d'une
invasion russe parce qu'il considérait
que c'était pas une impossibilité
militaire mais que c'était pas dans dans
l'intérêt du kremlin
peut-être d'ailleurs pas pas tort les
français savaient que la guerre allait
être difficile même pour les russes et
de ce point de vue là sans joie après on
voit bien que l'opération militaire
spécial du kremlin
sap a été les chars à kiev en cas de
jour on c'est une des leçons de ces 100
jours 100 jours donc on va faire le
point en kart évidemment avec avec vos
alexis vous réagissez sur youtube sur
tweets sur lefigaro.fr et je voudrais
commencer cela ils vont rendre hommage
évidemment à frédéric leclerc imhoff
journaliste de bfm tv tué tué lundi par
un éclat d'obus alors qu'ils tournaient
un reportage dans un convoi humanitaire
csa alexis l'image parce que tout ce que
peut vous expliquer alexis dans l'heure
qui vient il le doit en grande partie à
ses reporters qui sont sur le terrain et
qui rapporte des images un tous les
jours absolument il ya deux il ya deux
sources il ya évidemment le travail sur
le terrain
qui est exceptionnel et cap donc on peut
qu'on peut pas remplacer havas et le
sait le coeur du métier n'est nouveau
figaro ça fait 100 jours que les grands
reporters du service international ce
ils ont dans le pays se hisse relais
dans l'est dans les différentes villes
d'ukraine et là on a réalisé
à quel point ce métier était dangereux
et qu' il y avait des morts choc et une
dizaine de journalistes qui sont intimes
cinq minutes c'est ça
en 100 jours et voilà c'est inhérent au
métier mais là vraiment c'est que
évidemment ce qui est particulier 5 cc
et qui est proche évidemment nos
rédactions et à serge des gens bien sûr
alors singing et en plus il ya
énormément de jeunes journalistes qui
sont partis la couvrir et ça ça fait
voilà c'est aussi ça et on va le voir
mais c'est
c'est un éclat de but mais s était il
était pas avec l'armée ukrainienne à ce
moment là c'était un convoi humanitaire
et ont donc ça ça change vous avez
raison je salue maxence ms kamel qui
nous disent bonjour sur youtube
n'hésitez pas à vous poser vos questions
vous réagissez et justement cette
première carte
il était il était pas tout seul un
frédéric leclerc imhoff l'été avec
maxime brand stetter le reporter qui
l'accompagné avec oksana qui est la
fixeuse parce que tous les journalistes
qui partent sur le terrain ont des
spécialistes du coin qui les
accompagnent les aident à avoir des
contacts il était dans cette zone de
severodonetsk un zoom et un peu c'est
ici où on va on va zoom est évidemment
et pour voir de manière plus globale
c'est à peu près là où je mets la sto
petit peu plus et laissent aller à un
tout petit peu plus à l'aise ici
exactement exemple va donc vraiment dans
l'extrême est de l'ukraine et c'est là
où on lui aujourd'hui les les principaux
combats et c'est là où l'offensive russe
marque des points et donc voilà c'est
une ville c'est vers donesk et il ya
évidemment des couloirs humanitaires ou
les une partie des civils de la ville
sont partis et dont les couloirs couloir
humanitaire qui vont vers vers l'ouest
donc dans la zone
on voit bien cette forme-là de tenaille
cerner ce qu'est vraiment au bout de la
thonaille delà des couloirs humanitaires
qui passent vers l'ouest alors des
convois humanitaires pour exfiltrer les
habitants de severodonezk absolument qui
fuit comme comme dans toute guerre
causes comme accord commun souvent cette
image de marie rolland que quand même
marioupol abbas qui était ce qui était
particulier à marioupol s'est très
rapidement marioupol avait été encerclée
par les troupes russes donc les couloirs
humanitaires
étaient tenus malgré tout parlé par les
russes là il ya encore des routes qui
mènent vers la partie non contrôlés par
les donc c'est sur les routes qui vont
par exemple de severodonec vers cravate
horse par exemple ça tombe bien
absolument que nous comprenons que ces
routes
pour les pour les russes
ils souhaitent les contrôler parce que
c'est aussi par là que passent les la
rigueur les renforts ukrainiens ou à la
rigueur les les soldats ukrainien qui se
replierait pour aller vers l'ouest n'est
pas pour ne pas se faire capturer et c
est comme l'artillerie russe et
appartenant justement ça c'est la
question on ne sait pas pour l'instant
très peu d'informations à ce qu'on sait
s'ils étaient loin de la ligne de front
tout est possible mais on note que je ne
sais pas même s'ils ont jusque là aussi
c'est quand ces
convois humanitaires qui est censé être
dans une zone à la retirer russe
globalement un craignent va jusqu'à 30
40 km d'accord et là on sait que c'était
la route de l'isie chances que la ville
qui est juste à côté de la ville de sées
vernonnais sq voilà mais on n'a pas plus
de précisions
mais voilà c'est le alors il ya cette
habitude justement alexis
des russes qui attaquent des convois
humanitaires ça c'est pas la première
fois qu'on achète des écossais palerme a
déjà la preuve je veux dire mais ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'on entend
des réfugiés dire on a été attaqué
lorsqu'il arrive dans les villes et
attaqué un convoi militaire c'est ça
rentre dans ce qu'on appelle un crime de
guerre un acte que connaît lui aussi une
belle où on va on n'a pas le droit de
commettre un tel acte est donc ce qui
est intéressant c'est pour ça que le
l'office central de lutte contre les
crimes contre l'humanité qui est en
france a été saisie va enquêter et si
jamais il s'avérait que c'était un crime
de guerre il faudrait qu'il ya un procès
auprès d'une cour internationale mais ce
sont des procès qui prennent des années
c'est un reproche on fait souvent à
cette justice internationale mais
souvent si longtemps après la fin d'une
guerre donc là c'est la partie va dire
enquête et c'est des enquêteurs qui sont
à la fois des gendarmes des policiers
des aussi des militaires en l'espèce et
puis après il y aura là la partie judici
ainsi elle si elle a lieu un jour mais
ça ça prendra encore une fois des années
alors si frédéric et maxime les deux
journalistes de bfm était là là bas
c'est parce qu'il ya dans cette zone une
concentration de conflit vous me
confirmez donc là on a nouméa encore
plus proche de cette ligne de front donc
severodonetsk est ici un alexis je vous
laisse prendre la sonnerie parce que
comme ça vous allez pouvoir tout nous
montrer
c'est dans cette zone que se concentrent
en ce moment au milieu du dombass les
conflits alors en gros ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre donc là c'est le don est
peut-être qu'on pourrait revenir la
carte avant connais parce que c'est trop
alors 3 ou merrion bas
/ je vous montre va pas comprendre le
drame alors cette carte elle est ici
celle-ci vous vouliez absolument
peut-être commencer par la commencer par
le début entre guillemets la fête le
dombass ces deux régions celle de
lougansk est celle de donetsk
qui sont dans l'extrême est de l'ukraine
est en fait en 2014 je passe il vous
souvenez mais à une première guerre de
fait entre la russie et l'ukraine et les
séparatistes pro-russes appuyées par
l'armée russe avait conquis on va dire
une partie du dombass seleçao engrange
un pan plus avancé voilà voilà seulement
et donc à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est que les russes ça c'est un
objectif de guerre officiel essaye de
contrôler l'intégralité du dombass dont
on voit la ligne la démarcation qui est
la ligne hongrie ce qui passe d'accord
ici donc en au nord là dans la zone
orange envoie cette ligne et elle arrive
voilà elle entend servas oui par exemple
la ville de velika c'est ça c'est le
bout du donbass c'est absolument c'est
toute cette ligne qu'est l'argent fallu
grand-chose du dombass à récupérer là
quand je vois cette carte alors c'est on
en parlera tout à l'heure mais c'est
qu'ils contrôlent 90% de l'oblast la
région de lougansk est un peu peu la
moitié en gros 2 le blast 2 donesk est
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
les russes par ailleurs en 2014 avait
récupéré la crimée dont on voit un petit
bout ici est donc la grande bataille
décisive non base dans
laquelle on est actuellement
en fait c'est une bataille en tenaille
c'est bon je pense que la voie la crimée
je vois là vous montrer la crim est
arrivé jusqu'à zones orange ces soldes
ski qui sont récupérées depuis 2004
quatre français et orange plus clair
depuis le début de l'actionnariat 100
jours absolument et donc là on voit très
bien la manoeuvre russe cave est une
manoeuvre d'enveloppement une manoeuvre
de de tonnage qui consiste
peut-être un peu trop zoomer à passer
par l'avenue
sinon comprends pas vous avez le obscène
voilà est en fait ce qui se passe les
russes ne passe pas directement en avant
vers la maison si tu as une grande dame
à 9 d'enveloppement par le nord d'accord
c'est les territoires qu'ils contrôlent
déjà depuis le depuis le 24 février et
ils sont passés au sud par la crimée ils
ont remonté et c est donc ça fait les
deux pinces delà de la thonaille au sud
et puis au nord et donc c'est
verdonnaise c'est vraiment le bout de
cette taille et on en est là aujourd'hui
et donc maintenant pour le coup on va
comprendre m on va zoomer dans cette
partie quel âge vous l'âme on
s'attend cependant que pendant que je
zoome et que je trouve la bonne carte
celle qui convient alexis pour qu'il
vous explique parfaitement j'ai une
question 5 fruits et légumes qui me
demande sur youtube bonjour selon vous
quelle est la prochaine étape pour les
russes odessa ou se contenter de
stabiliser leurs nouveaux gains
territoriaux à l'est et au sud le mot
prochain
en tout cas odessa c'est impossible à
court terme d'accor et est ce que les
russes un jour iront à deux ça dépendra
de comment se passe la guerre dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois nous aujourd'hui ce n'est pas du
tout d'actualité
voilà le docteur la fin mai cette zone
alors c'est ça cette zone là c'est
vraiment aujourd'hui c'est le sujet il
est là alors pour bien comprendre en
fait c'est une région assez urbanisées
même s'il ya pas de très grands et sur
combien de kilomètres 100 150 ou
250 là est peut-être un peu moins de 200
ici
le voilà bien sûr et donc c'est une deux
régions à celles organisées avant la
guerre c'était les deux régions les plus
peuplées de d'ukraine avec dans chaque
don chaque à peu près 4 millions
d'habitants d'accord est en fait il ya
deux
de zone urbaine il ya severodonetsk et
lazy chance qu hélas ça fait un petit un
premier chapelet de vie alors c'est très
prochain c'est presque là mais voilà
elles sont collés simplement il ya une
rivière entre les deux ans la c-zéro
donne est 100 500 5600 et des échanges
j'ai regardé tout à l'heure 95000 voilà
c'est ça mais il sait des villes grandes
mais pas très grands moyens et plus à
l'ouest et un deuxième chapelet de ville
qu hélas l'audience qu ekra matters
d'accord travail sort qui est depuis
2014 la capitale ukrainienne de donetsk
puisque la ville de deux nièces et déjà
sous le contrôle des séparatistes donc
si vous voulez l'objectif final de la
bataille du tout neuf du dombass
cesser la violence et créateurs et donc
les russes avancent de l'est
vers l'ouest d'accord et donc ils ont
plusieurs tenaille la première étape
c'est de prendre ces verdonnais ce
cliché en ce qu est la deuxième ça sera
ce la violence qu'amateur sq est donc là
on voit très bien ce qui se dessine
puisque à l'intérieur de cette grande
menace développement manoeuvre
d'enveloppement il y en a une deuxième
plus petit avec cette ville à pau passes
n'a été prise hier c'est la loterie mais
ça y est voilà et donc vous voyez il ya
une pince à qui se forment et l'objectif
c'est de refermer je compte cette
tenaille dans la tenaille on en est là
aujourd'hui une sorte de siège et c'est
pour ça que les ukrainiens va un peu
comme à marioupol la question c'est est
ce que il reste assez verdonnaise
qualifiant ce qui est le risque d'être
coincé au bout d'un moment et là il
pourra t-on le plus longtemps possible
mais ils pourront pas partir ou est ce
que il essaye de se retirer par des
manoeuvres de freinage mais là on en est
là alors les russes n'ont pas
complètement fermé la taille pour un une
raisons géographiques il faut bien avoir
en tête c'est qu'il ya une rivière qui
passe oui quel le dos nièce d'accord il
faut que la douane y est plutôt est en
fait la ligne de front russe là
aujourd'hui c'est exactement cdh riviera
il n'arrive pas la traversée alors nos
jeunes cadets pont avant contre
n'importe les ponts la plupart ont été
détruits mais vous savez que les
militaires sont capables de créer des
points artificielle sur lesquels la
surpasse les passes les chars il ya eu
une tentative il ya à peu près de trois
semaines qui s'est soldée par un échec
tactique manifeste pour les russes donc
pour l'instant ils ne sont pas il reste
de ce côté-là delà de l'arrivée sauf que
c'est vers donesk et alès de la rivière
donc entre guillemets du côté russe et
donc tout l'enjeu voilà ses deux grands
numéros donesk ce serait presque plus
facile à prendre qui y voit la chanteuse
qui est de l'autre côté de l'absolu mais
retenons simplement ensuite les russes
peuvent quand même passé par là parce
que j'ai pas vous faire le cours de la
rivière mais ils ont ils peuvent plus
facilement la csu par le tribunal bien
que par le nom et ce qui se voit c'est
que la tenaille par le sud fonctionne
beaucoup mieux que par le nord voilà
j'ai des questions sur youtube alexis on
va on va continuer à avancer oui bsa
raison essayer de ne pas parler en même
temps s'il vous plaît oui c'est vrai je
vous coupe des fois l'excès gd une
petite question nous avons l'impression
en écoutant les médias occidentaux que
les seuls qui pratique des crimes de
guerre sont les russes et réponse de
bruno de toute façon une zone de guerre
c'est une zone de non droit les crimes
sont quotidiens tant de la part des
russes que de la part des ukrainiens
c'est vrai ça est ce que on peut
attester que les ukrainiens des crimes
de guerre je me souviens d'un aspect si
de doha humanitaire qu avaient expliqué
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas de guerre où
il n'y avait pas de crime de guerre ça
je pense que c'est une vérité assez
générale par ailleurs il ya eu des
crimes de guerre en tout cas des crimes
de guerre soupçonné côté ukrainien qui
ont été répertoriés depuis le début du
conflit on l'a on l'avait dit avait des
soldats russes qui avait été abattu à
bout portant par exemple donc donc voilà
maintenant il ya visiblement une brutale
et vos qualités russe qui semble
davantage manifester qu'on avait vu dans
les massacres de boudhha près de près de
près de kiev donc voilà après c'est le
travail de la justice internationale
mais bien sûr et c'est un travail qui
prend énormément de temps et le problème
c'est que souvent effectivement le le le
cette question des crimes de guerre
devient aussi un objet politique et ça
c'est inhérent la logique de la guerre
qui est aussi une guerre de
communication ça c'est le travail des
journées c'est de rester bien sûr très
froid même qu évidemment l'émotion
prend le pas christian les ont tous un
bon jour sur le cigare au point fr qui
remercie pour ces cartes oui on a un
très bon service infographie qui les
remet à jour évidemment alors cette
ville de severodonetsk on y revient et
les prises par les russes oui ou non
alors aujourd'hui hier 70 % et 70 % à
peu près c'est l'idée il ya encore des
combats contrairement à ce qu on avait
pu penser au début les et que les
ukrainiens ne se sont pas retirés
entièrement à lady chance il ya encore
des combats après les combats pour
l'instant ce sont quand même moins
violent et d'ailleurs les russes
avancent plus vite qu à marioupol par
exemple parce que la ville est moins
tenues etc les bassins sont c'est à dire
c'étaient
les ukrainiens vont probablement moins
au choc c'est l'impression qu'on a mais
faut vraiment parler avec des pincettes
tant c'est difficile d'avoir des
informations mais c'est le après le fait
que ces verdonnais va tomber ça ne fait
pas tellement de doute exactement quand
on ne sait pas mais on peut lire
quelques jours on parle pas en jours
maximum et là pour le coup je ne pense
pas me tromper après quelle sera la
suite j'ai commencé à vous le dire c'est
à dire que la la la thonaille par le sud
via via pop hasna elle va probablement
continuer il en fait l'essai de fley les
russes et la c5 absolument monter et à
la salle de la giraille et donc
connaître les russes essaye de contrôler
les principales routes
d'approvisionnement pour empêcher la
capacité de mouvement des ukrainiens et
par ailleurs il essaye de pousser vers
un bac mouthe qui est la ville alloue a
juste à l'ouest de pop hasna et qui
serait ça permettrait de d'avancer vers
l'ouest vers les deux villes dont j'ai
parlé qui sont les principales crama
tusk et la violence et l'autre chose
qu'on voit là si
bien sûr la souris c'est que la pince
nord delà de la taille le point central
c'est la ville 10e qui a été prise dès
le 1er avril d'ailleurs au moment de
suite tout de suite pas tout de suite
mais après de gros combat et c'est là
d'ailleurs que les russes ont annoncé
que leurs objectifs de guerre maintenant
officiellement c'était le dombass après
on sait pas quels seront les prochains
objectifs mais n'ont qu'à partir 10 yum
donc qu'est nos lames qui est pas adam
le blast de deux nièces et dans le blast
au dessus de kharkiv
dont les russes contrôlent toujours une
partie tout par 10 ou mme et on voit
qu'ils essayent de pousser vers le vers
le sud et aujourd'hui ils ont aussi pris
liman qui est un autre point
centrale et on voit que vraiment ils
sont proches aujourd'hui de cela vient
ce que je veux pas dire de bêtises mais
aujourd'hui la ville de slave y ans qui
est pas très loin elles mêmes à porter
probablement de de l'artillerie russe
donc voilà ça c'est une prochaine étape
c'est la viande crama 14 qui les
tenaillent qui vont continuer de s'en
tirer je lis quesne jean scène / /
twitch qui me dit oui les routes
principales sont sous le feu de
l'artillerie russe ça vous me disiez
l'instant les russes bombarde ces routes
d'accès plus tôt pour qu'on ne puisse
pas approvisionnée ou pour qu'on ne
puisse pas partir de ces les deux pattes
parce que la capacité de manoeuvre
ukrainienne c'est à la fois envoyé des
renforts s'ils veulent tenir un point et
c'est aussi
évacué en ordre dans ben bon ordre les
territoires où ils décident de 2,2 en
tirer donc c'est dans les deux sens jeux
jeux des zooms un peu pour que les gens
puissent se rendre voilà où on était à
la carte qu'on avait juste avant c'est
cette toute petite zone ici un abcès
vous avez une idée précise mais non tout
ce que vous me dites il y a trois
semaines un mois les russes se retire du
nord notamment autour de kiev sous le
nom se recentre vers le dombass et on
dirait les russes n'avance plus mais là
j'ai l'impression qu'ils avancent dans
ce que vous me dites alors devant le
dombass il annonce clairement simplement
on voit bien que l'échelle géographique
en serrant contre elle est tout à fait
réduite barras pekhart
24 février où les russes ont attaqué par
trois fronts au nord au sud à l'aise de
pays et où il avancé en dizaines de
kilomètres chaque jour et puis ça s'est
arrêté maintenant ils avancent pas en
dizaines de kilomètres par jour il
avance au mieux on quand quelques
kilomètres par jour et simplement
aujourd'hui c'est uniquement dans le nom
basse donc on a changé on a changé
d'échelle mais mais il avance il faut il
ya un point qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que dès le 24 février à peu près
40 à 50% des forces du crâniennes
étaient dans cette région du donbass
déjà déjà mais pour une raison très
simple c'est que depuis 2000 14 c'était
le centre du conflit
de 2014 donc évidemment il ya tellement
tout ça les séparatistes
qui a eu à lever ces les quarante 40 à
50% des forces l'ukrainienne ukrainienne
du coup je recommence c'est vraiment 40
50% défense ukrainienne ils sont dans la
région du delta ok c'est pour ça que les
russes au début avait pas tellement
avancé dans cette région là parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas intérêt d'aller aux chocs
là où il y avait le plus du crânien donc
en fait les combats en terme d'intensité
n'ont pas baissé avec cet acte 2 qui se
focalise dans le donbass par rapport à
l'acte 1 1 qui était une invasion
générale du pays le rapport de forces
est le même le nombre d'hommes est le
même les charges d'artillerie sont les
mêmes volumes est ce que à terme là on
peut dire il est raisonnable d'envisager
que
les russes prendront le nom basse
alors à terme devenir à long terme intel
mais est-ce que je
rendais bien c'est toujours mais frileux
face ils vont le faire peuvent le nom
basse oui ils peuvent oui ils peuvent ça
c'est ça c'est très clair et on a même
une idée de l'échelle de temps c'est à
l'horizon de un à deux mois mais voilà
après il ya la guerre via des
incertitudes des retournements des
évidemment n'y a aucune garantie mais
disons que c'est un objectif
militaire russe qui est tout à fait à
leur mesure cram à tort sq
c'est la grande ville ce serait un point
central oui
c'est un noeud un noeud ferroviaire etc
c'est une ville qui seraient très
importantes et politiquement poutine
surtout pourrait dire bah voilà on tient
le dombass donc là ça serait non plus
une victoire intermédiaire mais une
vraie victoire politique j'ai vu que 20%
du territoire ukrainien et est
aujourd'hui occupée par les russes
c'était ça l'objectif de base de poutine
alors si vous avez quel était l'objectif
je ne suis pas dans la tête de tout et
bien sûr simplement si on revient en
arrière donc on rappelle que le 24
février les russes attaques dans toutes
les directions à la fois bon sauf par
l'ouest puisqu'il n'a pas de frontière
avec la russie et notamment la majorité
des armées russes passent par la
biélorussie et vont vers kiev alors
selon vous propose regarder ce qu'on va
faire passer par un très bon article à 8
sur lefigaro.fr de nicolas barotte qui a
recensé regarder en kart le déroulé de
cette de cette guerre avec l'offensive
qui commence le 24 février l'offensive
russe ça c'est la première partie du 24
février au 12 mars un
offensive russe partout partout et en
réalise que je vous disais les russes
ont avancé vite et surtout donc la
majorité des armées étaient dans la
région de kiev la preuve personne par le
nord et par l'est donc au bout d'un
moment venir poutine peut dire ce qu'il
veut mais il est quand même probable que
l'objectif était de faire de décapiter
le gouvernement d'alliance qui alors
est-ce que après c'était pour annexer
puis en moins simplement l'ukraine
peut-être pas c'était peut-être pour
pour établir à kiev un autre
gouvernement encore été à la favorable
plus favorable on n'en sait rien mais en
tout cas le 7 sept acte 1 delà de la
guerre d'ukraine avait très certainement
cet objectif ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'il ya eu on le voit sur la carte une
impasse avec tout d'un coup les russes
n'ont plus réussi 13 mars au 27 mars non
plus réussi à avancer et en fait pour
une raison simple c'est qu'ils ont
avancé très vite parce qu'ils n'en fait
ils n'ont pas cherché à prendre les
villes ils ont cherché à avancer si long
des routes ouvertes à prendre les
centres voit par exemple un bon exemple
a soumis qui ne voilà t une vie sobre il
n'a jamais été pris mais ils ont avancé
quand même jusqu'à qui est absolument
partie contourner il contournait les
villes ils n'ont pas pris de charny
fille n'ont pas prêt qui a fait
évidemment ils n'ont pas prêt kharkiv
ils n'ont pas pris cela pour lui de
gérer ne pas présumer que la leaf et c
est en fait ils se sont retrouvés fin
mars avec un très grand nombre de sièges
et en face à des très grandes villes il
ya une erreur
oui alors il y avait une erreur
manifeste c'est que les russes sont
entrés en ukraine avec 150 à 200 mille
hommes l'ukraine ça fait plus de cinq
mille kilomètres carrés six à sept mille
c'est plus grand que la queue que la
france vouloir prendre un pays comme la
comme la france avec 150 à 200 mille
soldats
c'est extrêmement étonnant du point de
vue la stratégie militaire et donc kiev
pour faire le siège de kiev il fallait
tenir une zone avec un périmètre de 150
km autour du kef les russes n'en avait
pas les moyens et donc ils se sont
enlisés autour de ces sièges urbain et
on sait que les les guerres de siège les
guerres urbaines il ya un avantage aux
défenseurs et donc là les revues à marly
absolument exemple est donc là le fin
mars les russes se disent on n'y
arrivera pas il faut changer de braquet
et là les russes annoncent
officiellement qui concentrent leurs
forces dans l'est de l'ue elle est donc
toutes les troupes russes sont retirés
en catastrophe du nord c'est donc cerner
au 27 mars ça fait presque deux semaines
entre 13 et le 27 10 et ça bon l'armée
russe n'avance plus vous pouvez
descendre un petit peu alexis c'est sûr
voix et de l'atlas ukrainienne sauf que
ça ça se fête les deux se font en même
temps sir que les russes commencent dès
le 28 mars la bataille du dombass elle
vous ai dit que la ville d'izu n'a été
prise le 1er avril donc les russes
commencent d'ores et déjà leurs
manoeuvres d'enveloppement du dombass et
pendant ce temps là les ukrainiens
récupère les territoires dans le nord
repousse les russes dehors les gens et
là on arrive on ne peut remonter un peu
on voyait qu'au dessus il y avait là
dans cette carte une partie orange
l'avancé l'avancé virus et lorsque vous
démarrez en effet plus rien et là y'a
plus rien et là on voit une carte et
finalement si on dézoomer ressemble
beaucoup à celle d'aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui les combats se focalise
vraiment dans cette région lorsqu'il ya
c'est que les russes n'avance plus sur
cette ligne de front au sud ils ont
essayé de consolider leur position sans
vraiment essayer la nouveauté ils ont
essayé avait remis cola est
anémique nikolaïev à court terme n'est
pas un objectif de là aussi elle mais on
avance le nom mariage ils ont ils ont
essayé parce qu'ils avaient l'objectif
de dessins qui n'ont jamais réussi à
prendre ni qu en réalité très rapidement
ça n'était pas possible accord alors il
décide de maintenir une pression faite
pour fixer des troupes ukrainienne à
odessa pour que les toutes les troupes
ukrainienne n'aille pas dans le donbass
mais pour le coup c'était entre
guillemets une diversion mick depuis la
fin mars mais que la leaf n'est plus un
objectif le russe dont qui se consolide
derrière cette grande ville qui
s'appelle carson et voilà il ya des
contre attaques des deux côtés mais qui
sont pas des contre attaques de très
très très intenses et corps et des
objectifs stratégiques s'est dé contre
attaque tactique et voilà maintenant
face dans la bataille de nos masses
d'accord alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les ukrainiens ont tenté il ya
à peu près trois semaines
une première contre-offensive dans la
région de kharkiv kharkiv qui est la
deuxième ville d'ukraine un million et
demi d'habitants ça fait partie de ces
villes que les russes n'ont pas réussi à
prendre parce que à siéger une ville
d'un million et demi d'habitants font
énormément
la plus grosse ville prise par les ruses
jusqu'ici et carson ces cars seuls
habitants voilà on n'a rien paul à
l'origine c'était aussi qu'à l'origine
c'était aussi 4,5 me no mi temps voilà
c'est laisser les deux grandes villes sa
jambe carson un statut de capitale
régionale ce que n'a pas de mari paul
ghislaine qui nous dit c'est très
complexe qui s'y passe oui oui c'est
vrai que c'est complexe et on essaye de
vous expliquer ça au mieux donc on en
revient à ce chiffre 20 % du territoire
est occupé aujourd'hui sachant qu'une
partie de ce territoire est absolu un
nom était déjà occupé en 2014 avec la
crimée et une partie du nom d'alain ce
qui fait une à française c'est bien on
va être très pratique j'ai fait un petit
tableau voilà en 2014 les russes ont
réussi à occuper avec la crimée et la
partie du dombass quarante mille
kilomètres carrés donc cette partie
c'était 7 on peut la voir sur la carte
c'est cette partie en orange clair ici
voilà voilà il vaut mieux c'est la
partie s du voile abbas et la clé mais
voila voila ca c 40 mille kilomètres
carrés ces 7 % du territoire ukrainien
et c'est l'équivalent des pays bas
d'accord voilà ça c'est la première
chose aujourd'hui les russes sont passés
de 40 mille kilomètres contrôlé à 113
mille kilomètres carrés sa chance
concrète est ici sans mobile en km 15
ici on voit l'argent donc en gros depuis
le depuis le 24 février les russes ont
conquis soixante dix mille kilomètres
carrés ce qui représente 12 % du
territoire ukrainien et au total avec
les territoires de 2014 on monte à 19%
voilà c'est à la louche donc venir % 20
% c'est ce qu'a annoncé zelensky ça
n'est pas rien c'est un tiers de
l'allemagne ces 20% de la france c'est
plus grand que la hongrie plus grand que
l' autriche et ses trois fois et demi la
belgique
alors vous me dites que c'est important
et c'est vrai que c'est important
quelles sont ces territoires ce sont des
territoires dévastés mario paul on prend
marioupol mes pattes mars de marioupol
tattoo cécile ou détruites alors
marioupol est une ville complètement
détruite si vous prenez la partie sud
notamment carson mais radiance skis et
herat il n'y a pas tellement eu de
combats urbains et les ailes et les
villes ne sont globalement pas très
détruites il ya évidemment des traces de
lanières c'est inévitable par ailleurs
contrairement aux territoires
où les rues sont avancés au nord pendant
l'acte 1 est en réalité il ne tenait pas
les territoires il était passé à travers
mais ça s'est étonné le dire il tenait
pas les villes et ne tenait pas
aujourd'hui dans tout le sud de
l'ukraine est évidemment dans le nom
basse ont été mises en place des
administrations double à la fois civile
et militaire et donc les russes occupent
et contrôler ces territoires si vous
allez à kherson ou a perdu ans que au
bord de la mer d'azov
aujourd'hui vous utiliser le rouble eux
je crois même que ça y est les salaires
vont être payés en roubles oui au delà
de la guerre il ya eu donc cibler ses 21
ans politique là ça y est dynamique
politique et c'est vraiment 20%
de l'ukraine que les que les russes
contrôle vraiment maintenant les choses
ne sont pas figées dans un sens comme
dans l'entente puisque tout à l'heure
j'ai dit que les ukrainiens avaient
tenté des contresens il ya la contre
offensive au nord par kharkiv oui parce
qu'en fait les celle là qui est
absolument russie pour l'eau alors qui a
été réussi mais arrêtez c'est qu'elle
arrive elle arrive maintenant au début
et j'ai dit allons y avait une rivière
les ukrainiens on met une tête de pont
sur la rivière mais ils n'ont pas réussi
à avancer ou alors deux ans qu'il ya une
ville où il ya une de celles de belgorod
années 50 ces concentrations une ville
russe où il ya une très grande
concentration
c'est le sait le point nodal en russie
pour toutes les forces russes et donc en
fait cette contre offensive ce qui était
aussi une manoeuvre dans l'autre sens
c'était pour attaquer les les eaux les
lignes d'approvisionnement
russe pour empêcher ensuite les russes
de se battre dans le nom basse elle a
été un succès au début aujourd'hui les
les ukrainiens n'arrive pas réellement
aller au delà dans cette contre
offensive est aujourd'hui ce qui est
intéressant depuis à peu près une
semaine il ya une deuxième contre
offensive qui est à l'exact opposé qui
au niveau de carson a on va en parler de
ma personne évidemment on l'a dit
premières grandes villes prises par les
russes c'est la seule capitale régionale
oui c'était c'est là le chef-lieu de
l'oblast de carson ça a été fait assez
rapidement quatre cent mille habitants
carson et il y as depuis plusieurs
semaines une contre offensive sur cette
ville depuis une semaine une semaine a
laissé quelques jeux parce que je me
souviens il ya quelques temps que
nikolaïev qui est la ville suivante sur
la route de dessin on voit ici dans le
sud étaient attaqués les russes n'ont
vraisemblement vraisemblablement pas du
tout réussi à s'approcher nikolaïev ils
ont reculé et là maintenant vraiment
contre-offensive sur trois personnes non
pas sur l'éducation à un hors de la
ville de carson faire qu'en fait il ya
une pareille toujours pareil et une
rivière qui s'appelle ligne in houlette
qui passe juste à dire bas sur la ligne
de front tout simplement et donc les
ukrainiens au nord entre créé viry et
carson où on réussit à faire une tête de
pont et à passer au delà maintenant on a
extrêmement peu d'informations
les russes et les ukrainiens pour
l'instant ne publie pas tellement de
l'information sur les zones contrôlées
sur les villages contrôle etc donc on
sera extrêmement prudent ce qui est
clair c'est que la contre offensive est
toujours en cours
voilà maintenant on verra dans quelques
jours ce qu'il en est mais il faut bien
comprendre l'objectif stratégique no 7
de cette contre offensive c'est que
s'ils arrivent à menacer carson la
russie donc pourrait perdre cette
capitale régionale et surtout la région
de kherson ils la tiennent vraiment et
ils veulent la conserver et donc si
pendant qu'ils aient dû prendre le nom
bas ils perdent le blast de carson c'est
un jeu à somme nulle vous avez la
poutine ne pourra jamais dire même s'il
arrivait à voir le nom bassi pourra
jamais dire que c'est une victoire donc
là c'est vraiment vous êtes en train de
dire que même si on parle moins de ce
qui se passe dans le suisse est
extrêmement adroit base dont base dont
basse qui revient avec cette guerre du
dombass mais c'est le contre offensive
allait presque autant d aussi décisive
et elle est plus décisif que la contre
offensive de kharkiv est ce que kharkiv
gillot est utile aux russes mais à ce
stade il ne souhaite pas contrôler le
blast de kharkiv il souhaite obtenir une
partie au fait pour protéger d'accord le
leur attaquant comme naumann l'avait dit
tout à l'heure car qu'il n'a jamais été
prise par le russe ils ont pas réussi ça
je pense qu'ils aimeraient bien ils
n'ont pas réussi parce qu'il ya un
million et demi d'habitants s'ils
perdaient les russes car personne ça
serait très très dérangeant pour eux et
il faudrait qu'ils prennent des troupes
du nom basse pour les envoyer vers
personnes enfin ça serait compliqué
maintenant ce qu'on observe à kharkiv
que comme à carson c'est que les
manoeuvres ukrainienne peuvent bien
fonctionné au début mais après elles ont
du mal à manoeuvrer alors une raison qui
peut l'expliquer c'est un l'artillerie
russe qui est extrêmement puissante et
par ailleurs les russes n'ont pas le
contrôle du ciel sur toute l'ukraine
donc ils ont
en fait depuis le début comprends pas
très bien pourquoi il ya peu
relativement peu d'utilisation de
défense aérienne russe
alors c'est vrai au niveau général
probablement parce que les avions russes
ont du mal à a précisément
taper leurs leur cible est par ailleurs
ils n'ont pas détruit entièrement les
défenses aériennes
ukrainienne qui concerne même une chasse
pas énorme mais elle existe en revanche
localement c'est dire dans les
territoires qui sont proches des lignes
de front russe donc typiquement à carson
le nom basse là il ya une dominance
aériennes russes qui est massive et
notamment il utilise des avions ce qu'on
appelle d'attac au sol des sukhoï 25 et
des hélicoptères d attaque des cas 52
mi-28 et qui eux pilonnent les forces
d'ukrainiens et ça pour les forces du
colonel c'est vraiment une difficulté
qui font que leur contre attaque elles
ont du mal à tenir dans la durée à aller
en profondeur dans l'est dans les
territoires contrôlés par la russie on
va parler dans un instant des armes que
vont procéder bientôt les russes avec ce
que lille réalisent les ukrainiens
pardon avec ce que ce que sont en train
de livrer les américains dans un instant
et on reste encore un petit moment sur
sur carson vous réagissez encore sur
youtube sur lefigaro.fr sur twitter on
essaye de répondre à toute vocation nous
sommes en direct il est 15h30 si cela
fait 100 jours que cette offensive des
russes en ukraine que cette guerre en
ukraine a commencé et on fait le point
en kart personnes on en a parlé un peu
au début de ce live parce que l'un de
nos
nos internautes nous poser la question à
la base c'était le chemin vers rodez ça
absolument une fois tout prix garder
cette ville est ce que c'est encore
envisagée odessa vraiment je pense que
ça ne quittera pas la tête des stratèges
du kremlin ça m'étonnerait
énormément en revanche je pense qu'ils
ont tout à fait conscience que ça n'est
pas un objectif à court voire à moyen
terme enfin c'est encore si on fait le
calcul il faut déjà gardé carson et
ensuite il veut prendre nicolas il faut
prendre nikolaïev parce qu'il y a lebouc
méridionale voyait c'est ce fleuve un
qui dit si c'est ça et ensuite ils sont
allés le seul pont pour traverser ce
fleuve est à micola yav seul mais
ensuite il faut prendre au dessin et
donc c'est à dire étendre encore les
lignes de front russe donc c'est des
problèmes en matière de soutien c'est
très compliqué et encore une fois ils
ont pris 20% de l'ukraine ils ont pris
l'équivalent
de la fin plus que les pays bas soit
trois fois et demi la belgique avec
150000 à 200000 hommes c'est pour
l'instant le kremlin n'a pas engagé sur
le terrain les réservistes ou les ou où
les conscrits il y en a très peu
visiblement déconstruit il n'y a pas la
mobilisation générale est donc pour
l'instant les buts de guerre russe
ils y sont pas extensibles donc s'il
gagne le dombass s'il gagne le dombass
et selon l'état des forces russes après
cette bataille peut-être qu'ils pourront
ils envisager une percée vers l'ouest ou
une percée plus au nord en remontant le
nid après le grand fleuve qui traverse
le cren de monsieur d'honneur est ici
est allé vers la bridja et ni pro mais
franchement là on parle concrètement de
septembre oui septembre ou octobre et
appalachian sa très courte et après il y
aura la saison des boues à l'automne et
on suit
il y aura l'hiver et c est donc là on
commence à se dire que potentiellement
on est dans une guerre vraiment longue
j'ai une question de machiavel et qui
rejoint celle que je voulais poser merci
machiavel quel intérêt aurais la
transnistrie ici c'est cette zone
absolument rouge avec ce petit rien qui
est une zone de la région de l'âme alors
c'est une région séparatiste à voir ce
que c'est une région séparatiste pro
russe de moldavie et qu'elle
séparatistes depuis 91 donc est la chute
de lurs et depuis 91 il ya quelques
trous bruce 2000 dans mon souvenir qui
tiennent la région voilà voilà donc il
faut se dire vous je vous pose la
question quand même quel intérêt y at il
des ressources particulières là bas et
je complète la question vous me parliez
la dernière fois de cette nouvelle
russie alors rappelez nous aussi ce que
c'est parce qu'on se demande souvent ce
que peuvent être les objectifs de la
dîmière poutine ça ça me paraît être un
objectif potentiel possible pas ce qui
est intéressant c'est que l'objectif
officiel on l'a dit si les dons baissent
oui mais en revanche qui commence à
monter du côté des séparatistes chez
dans la propagande du régime ils ont
bien compris qu'ils pourraient pas avoir
l'ukraine dans son ensemble à court ou
moyen terme peut-être même long terme et
donc ils ont ressuscité une entité
administrative qui existait au 19e
siècle du temps de l'empiré russe et qui
était la nouvelle russie et qui grosso
modo correspondra saurez vous prend
l'air la souris c'est tout vous coupez
le l'ukraine en deux essais de l'ouest
là de l'un d'eux la trempe de la
transnistrie
jusqu'au don basse à leur quartier ne
faisait pas partie c'est tout ça et donc
concrètement avec ni pro par exemple
avec denis provent de tout c'est toutes
ces villes tout le sud de de l'empiré
russe aux 19e et qui en fait étaient les
territoires qu'elle était conquis contre
l' empire
ottoman ce qui s'est passé depuis 2014
les séparatistes pro russes ont
ressuscité ce concept de nouveaux rossia
pour dit on va aller jusqu'à aussi à la
nouvelle russie nouvelle russie pour dit
on va aller jusqu'à jusqu'à odessa et
donc c'est probablement un concept
politique
politique historique et nationalistes
une réalité historique mais c'est devenu
un concept politique nationaliste qui
est important et ce à une réalité on va
dire de rendre plus stratégiques c'est
que imaginer que l'ukraine soit privé de
cette nouvelle russie mais c'est à dire
qu'elle n'a plus d'accès à la mer noire
et ça pour les russes on peut imaginer
que c'est un objectif mais encore une
fois de long terme puisqu'on peut on
peut difficilement imaginer que la
bataille du dombass se termine avant la
fin de l'été parlons des armes un peu d
y mar c'est ça ils marquent ce dédit
marche pas comme en prononçant et
prenons simplement parce que ces voix là
non plus je ne savais pas ce que c'était
ce matin mais alexis m'a tout expliqué
il va tout vous expliquer alors c'est ea
mars ils sont au centre de l'attention
en ce moment qu'est ce que c'est alors
je ne vais pas répondre immédiatement à
votre question prenez votre temps prend
un chemin détourné ce qui est frappant
avec la bataille du dombass et que c'est
avant tout une bataille d'artillerie et
on avait été étonné d'ailleurs si les
grandes spécialités soviétique depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale et on avait été
étonné au début de l'invasion russe de
voir qu'il y avait un faible usage de la
retirer acte 2 de la guerre donc depuis
que c'est le dombass la l'artillerie
russe
résonne vraiment à plain et c'était
michel goya je crois qu'ils disaient que
la la capacité de tir russe et 200 mille
bus par jour c'est absolument alors que
le sale ça donne une idée et il va donc
c'est une bataille d'artillerie et donc
dans les deux batailles d'artillerie on
ne tire pas forcément sur des objets
qu'on voit on tire sur des objets qui
sont plus éloignés et donc ces déportés
de 20 30 40 50 km et donc inde un des
enjeux essentiels pour gagner une
bataille d'artillerie c'est évidemment
la portée des armes at il pas d'autres
par leur précision et une troisième
chose c'est là c'est la vitesse à la
galerie t l'âme la mobilité la vitesse
avec laquelle on peut reconnaître une
cible l'acquérir vincor et ensuite se
protéger par ailleurs et donc voilà
c'est un peu une équation à plusieurs
inconnues et lé les russes ont un
avantage massif dont le nombre de pièces
d'artillerie dans la puissance de feu
non dans la quantité quantité dans la
corde d'une puissance de feu d'accord
voilà et est donc là les ukrainiens ont
un des avantages
très claire de surtout qu'au départ il
avait à peu près les mêmes armes que les
russes puisque avant c'était l'union
soviétique
ce qui se passe c'est que depuis 2014
l'armée ukrainienne était formée par les
occidentaux et depuis le début du
conflit il ya énormément d'armes
occidentales qui sont acheminés
en année ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on voit que c'est des armes qui
deviennent de plus en plus lourdes avec
des portées de plus en plus élevés au
début c'était des missiles portatifs à
l'épaule qu'on était faible portée et
qui était surtout là ce qu'on peut
appeler communément lance-roquettes
c'est ça oui c'est ça ben bongo c'était
des armes antichars d'accord des armes
antichars parce que l'acteur s'était
surtout une guerre de chat là on est
dans une garde d'artillerie donc les les
ukrainiens ont besoin de pièces
d'artillerie pour pour tenir et donc on
avait vu qu'on a commencé à voir arriver
des ddo buzy m 777 âme et américains
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée là
c'est une portée de j'ai noté la 40 km
maximum après les fortes et dépendent
des
munitions utilisées mais leur portée
maximale c'est 40 km ça donne un ordre
de grandeur les français ont donné des
canons aude sur des camions césar qui
ont une porte est légèrement supérieur
de 40 à 50 km et déjà il avait pris un
petit avantage sur les russes dont le
budget principal le qui s'appelle le 2
aces 19 on a une portée de 30 km alors
la petite inversion du rapport de force
oui enfin ça c'est une sorte de cassure
cette bataille il ya une sorte de montée
aux extrêmes en l'air on a vu les russes
qui ont sorti leurs deux s7 qui est un
énorme olivier de 2 107 mm de calibre la
plupart des obusiers cédé 155 mm en
prenant de massy dans 152 aussi donc on
en a grossi et là la porte et ses 55 km
d'accord voilà escalade c'est une sorte
d'escaladé par ailleurs il ya un autre
type d'armes s'appelle les lance
roquettes multiples les orgues de
staline qui tire plein de roquettes très
rapidement c'est les fameux grade
soviétique alors là la dernière version
russe c'est le ce match qui va jusqu'à
90 km de portée et donc là les les
américains donc s'il ya une sorte de
deux d'escaladé d'artillerie on dit là
on va sortir le plus lourd c'est à dire
des dénonciations seller mlrs et lazy
mars il mars voilà donc l'appareil
d'accord et là on parle de 70 80 km de
portée et surtout là où il ya un énorme
avantage par rapport aux russes c'est
que c'est beaucoup plus précis d'une
part et d'autre part c'est
lui qu'il était très mobile parce que
sur un mobile parce que placer sur des
blindés légers oui et puis par ailleurs
il ya moins d'hommes pour manier ces
pierres est d'accord ça va plus vite etc
les systèmes sont sont plus modernes et
donc là ça peut donner un avantage
tactique aux ukrainiens mais un avantage
tactique il faut mettre par ailleurs en
parallèle avec la quantité d'artillerie
russe qui elle demeure absolument
massive par rapport rien parce qu'on les
biens en seront livrés ou ça ça reste ce
que ça reste secret mais mais mais alors
on peut on peut donner un chiffre par
exemple l'armée française je crois à 70
canon caesar on en a donné
je crois que c'est une petite dizaine on
a une dizaine vous voyez ce papier de
marilyn michalik guerre en ukraine les
nouveaux lance-roquettes multiples
américains peuvent-ils changer la donne
vous pouvez trouver cet article mais
vous avez la réponse d'alexis tout de
suite alors est-ce que ça peut changer
la donne un petit peu quand même parce
que 80 km ça permet d'aller très loin en
arrière
des lignes de front russe et si les tirs
sont précis appuyé par des
reconnaissances par l'ap un drone avec
tout le renseignement occidental par
ailleurs eh ben ça peut vraiment mettre
à mal les russes mais j'ai envie de vous
remontrer cette carte finalement est ce
que par exemple depuis une ville comme
claude nikolaïev peut-être pas mais en
tout cas dans cette partie vous me
parlez de la compare par exemple quelle
claque hier personne carson est
clairement c'est à peu près la distance
avec le point le plus proche
de tenues par les parlers par les
ukrainiens alors il me mettront
peut-être pas les en batterie juste à la
formulation dans la vie mais s'il
voulait ça vous donne un ordi décès
d'une sorte de profondeur tactique ou
aux ukrainiens qui est non négligeable
alors l'ukraine a donné des gages et
s'est engagé auprès des etats-unis qui
n'ont pas livré ses armes sans raison
c'est à dire que voilà l'ukraine ne peut
pas faire n'importe quoi avec césar
alors ce que je vous ai dit c'est que la
la la la portée de 80 km si on va dire
avec les avec les roquettes par ailleurs
ces systèmes d'armes sont capables
d'employer des missiles qui s'appelle
attaque attaque ms et qui vont une
portée de 300 km donc là on change dans
de grandes heures et donc la bei den a
été très clair il a dit on ne donne pas
si missiles donc on s'arrête ou 80
kilomètres pour quoi et par par ailleurs
il a demandé aux ukrainiens il est exigé
des ukrainiens qu'il ne tape pas le
territoire russe arina parce que par
exemple avec défense uniquement
des dépenses la défense de son propre
terrain oui c'est en tout cas pas c'est
aussi une attaque contre attaque c'est
une attaque reste à faire mais en tout
cas il ne tape rompt pas le territoire
russe on peut imaginer par exemple que
ces missiles auraient pu taper la ville
de belgorod dont parlait tout à l'heure
eh bien ça les américains ont exigé des
ukrainiens qu'ils n'aillent pas jusque
là justement pour qui est quand même une
une maîtrise dont l' escalade parce que
voilà c'est pas jusqu'où ça pourrait
nous mener comment on les achemine césar
alors pas par la mer non puisque il ya
un blocus
probablement pas par les airs parce que
quand même là
les moyens de lutte anti aérienne russes
existe donc sépare la terre par la terre
on imagine que les russes vont essayer
de cibler
insérées là c'est intéressant parce que
je vous ai dit que les américains leur
enseignement j'imagine le plus y avoir
un secret absolu pour savoir par où
passer les idées molles vente mais je
vous ai dit que les ukrainiens les
américains avaient demandé aux
ukrainiens de ne pas taper le territoire
russe mais en revanche les russes ne
tape tout le territoire
ukrainien et ce dès le début du conflit
parce que les russes disposent aussi de
missiles qui sont des missiles à courte
portée ou à portée intermédiaire donc là
on parle de porter de
jusqu'à 500 voire les navires en mer
noire et leurs missiles kalima sont
déportés de 1500 2000 km
ils peuvent taper n'importe quelle ville
en ukraine on a vu beaucoup de domicile
qu'on tapait une ville comme le vif à
l'extrême ouest de l'ukraine mais ce qui
se passe c'est que les stocks russes
domicile de précision ne sont pas
extensibles à l'infini les les
estimations début du conflit s'était
2000 l'a visiblement les russes ont
utilisé plus de 2000
mhz et donc là ils ont un problème c'est
qu'ils n'ont probablement plus
énormément domicile de précisions on
voit qu'ils utilisent des missiles de
plus en plus anciens ils utilisent des
missiles
destiné à l'origine à la lutte
antinavire contre la terre ce qui veut
dire qu'ils ont un problème
d'approvisionnement et donc ça si les
russes ne sont plus en mesure de taper
très en arrière le territoire ukrainien
jusqu'à le vif bah ça pour eux ça sera
une difficulté parce que c'est un
avantage stratégique qu'ils ont par
rapport à l'ukraine la diplomatie dans
tout ça alexis et je vois cette question
sur youtube qui m'amène à ça est ce que
la crimée est considérée comme russe ou
ukrainienne pour les américains
j'imagine que la la la la la la la
réponse extrêmement sain de peu du point
de vue du droit international il ya pas
à tortiller pour tous les occidentaux la
came une chrétienne voilà mais à un
moment ou un autre mais malgré ma si les
négociations est ce que ces choses-là
pourrait être négociée est ce que
semaine on peut pas l'exclure dans les
semaines à venir en 10 questions là là
on parle à l'horizon de plusieurs mois
on peut pas et que c'est l'un des
scénarios alors je vous conseille à une
nonne de bruno tertrais qu un
stratégiste français si on les
différents scénarios ça une sorte de
paix négociée fait partie des
des scénarios futurs alors on pourrait
par exemple imaginer
que les ukrainiens et les russes
se décide à laisser aux russes le le
dombass et la crimée c'est pas pour
autant que du point de vue juridique
internationalement les états unis
reconnaîtront la crimée rue st j'entends
annonay ou de ces négociations j'ai
l'impression qu'elles sont point mort ne
vous entend plus parler au début elles
sont il y avait des réunions
biélorusse mais là c'est plus non c'est
plus d'actualité pour une raison simple
c'est que les russes avancent malgré
tout d'en bas qu'ils ont aucun intérêt
pour l'instant à négocier et d'autre
part les ukrainiens
il ya 20% de leur territoire qui est
pris je vois mal zelensky
commencé à négocier ça montre une sorte
de faiblesse et puis par ailleurs les
ukrainiens il voit le soutien à la fois
militaire économique etc des occidentaux
ils se disent la vie à juste titre
qu'un retournement
militaires en leur faveur n'est pas non
plus impossible donc même militairement
pour eux ils n'ont pas forcément intérêt
à arrêter le combat parce que peut-être
que les russes vont vont s'enliser
peut-être qu'une contre-offensive à
carson a pas fonctionné que ces gens
tout cas l'heure n'est pas aux
négociations
j'ai une question enfin une petite
marche arrière mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
vait intéressante foot magazine foot
magazine qui est là avec nous la russie
prendra ses armes en cas de retrait des
ukrainiens les armes livrées par les
américains c'est l'inquiétude j'ai
probablement déclic études et c'est
quelque chose qu'on a déjà vu sur le
terrain puisqu'on a vu par exemple des
missiles portatifs on parlait tout à
l'heure
américain on les a vus dans les mains
dans les mains des russes et je crois
même que les russes ont publié des
manuels d'utilisation en russe
donc c'est une dame qui tue c'est une
réalité mais après c'est une sorte de de
ratio est ce que c'est utile ou pas
utile moi j'en reviens à la diplomatie
macron doit-il aller en ukraine ça c'est
une vraie question en ce moment et où
est ce qu'il pourrait aller à kiev
oui pourrait aller à kiev visiblement
cessé dans les cartons mais il peut pas
y aller si c'est juste une
visite pour faire les ongles pour faire
une photo ça ne sert à rien on la police
la france a une position on va dire
délicate c'est qu'elle ne fait pas
partie des déficiences les plus jusqu'au
boutiste d'un point de vue militaire
très clairement on sent que la france
mais aussi d'une certaine manière
l'allemagne se disent qu'un jour ou
l'autre il faudra bien négocier
avec les russes et que les ukrainiens
voilà on ne peut pas aller jusqu'à l'
escalade parce que par ailleurs ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que si jamais
un jour les ukrainiens reprenait
l'avantagé
est vraiment battait les russes sur le
sur le terrain vladmir poutine d'après
des militaires à des capacités d
escalade
donc est ce qu'on a envie d'avoir
militairement une telle escalade ça
n'est pas certain une question vous me
dîtes si vous n'avez pas la réponse
comment ça se passe quand un chef d'état
va sur plage in que c'est très sécurisé
est ce qu on peut être sûr qu'il
n'arrive rien emmanuel macron qu'il ne
pouvait rien arriver à catherine colonna
lorsqu'il y est allé la ministre des
affaires étrangères la semaine dernière
sa jumelle que c'est très contrôlé et
que les russes doivent faire attention
aussi à ne pas tirer la wii c'est ça que
je peux je pense qu'il ya des comptes
enfin il doit avoir des contacts pour
pour s'assurer qu'un pad
pas de problème pour le mans au tour
d'emmanuel macron on n'en est pas à ce
point
d'escale à de politique pour contrer
l'image innue
telle chose alors le temps presse avant
les négociations parce que ça ajoute en
ce moment une crise alimentaire
absolument c'est une des armes russes
très clair non ah ah oui ça faisait
clairement contrôlé par les russes ce
n'est pas c'est ce qu'ils veulent oui
c'est à dire qu'en fait le à la fois
l'ukraine il se trouve que l'ukraine et
la russie sont parmi les plus grands
exportateurs de céréales dans le monde
et notamment leurs céréales va
traditionnellement au maghreb en afrique
et au moyen-orient et donc par ailleurs
aujourd'hui il ya un blocus russe dans
le grand port d'odessa nom dont on a
parlé donc le grain ukrainien ne peut
pas quitter la mer noire est allé en
afrique au maghreb et c est par ailleurs
vu la guerre les récolte ukrainienne
cette année vont être absolument
désastreuse on imagine bien et donc ça
c'est une arme de négociation
pour la russie qui pourraient être
prêtes à alléger le blocus à laisser
passer des bateaux ukrainiens chargés de
blé à condition d'obtenir quelque chose
en échange cent jours alexis on en vient
à la fin de ce live et j'ai envie de
vous poser une question et maintenant et
maintenant que va-t-il se passer est ce
qu'on
je vais vous décevoir je ne sais pas le
jeu je ne vous demande pas d'être madame
irma mais quelles sont les hypothèses en
tout cas la plus probable c'est une
guerre longue dans le donbass j'avais
l'impression que je pense que l'on peut
dire on peut dire malgré tout qu'une
guerre longue c'est à dire qui se
comptent au moins un mois
et est aujourd'hui probable pour une
raison simple c'est qu'on ne voit pas
d'issue
diplomatique est par ailleurs les russes
malgré tout avance donc de ce point de
vue là il ya aucune raison d'être
optimiste
après tout dépendra aussi du sort de la
bataille du no mas est ce que les russes
vont l'emporter est ce que ce sera d'ici
l'été quel sera l'état de leurs forces à
l'issue de cette bataille décisive et
ensuite qu'est ce qu'ils décideront de
faire est ce que ça sera de prolonger le
les combats ou d'obtenir une sorte de
paix négociée en se disant on a sécurisé
personne n'a pour age est
le nom basse qui représentons lundi cent
mille ou cent cinquante mille kilomètres
carrés voilà ce qu'on pourrait dire vous
pouvez dire pour être tout à fait
complet sur et bien ces 100 jours 100
jours de deux guerres en ukraine vous
pouvez continuer à suivre évidemment
tout ce qui se passe en ukraine sur sur
lefigaro.fr vous avez ce direct avec
chaque information qui tombe avec les
propos de chacun la victoire sera un
autre affirme c'est un ski après 100
jours de présence russe merci beaucoup
alexis faire claquer merci beaucoup et
puis évidemment on continue nous à
suivre affaire de routine et un point
technologie doit pour le monde du cloud
oui il y aura probablement d'autres live
et on verra si la russie continue
d'avancer en ukraine merci beaucoup
merci de nous avoir suivi l'actualité
continue évidemment sur figaro live avec
tout le week-end le jubilé de la reine
ça c'est une autre actualité et on suit
également cette actualité là de l'autre
côté de la manche on se retrouve très
vite merci bonne journée à bientôt